I turn now to my right and see one of my
favorite players that I have known
thanks to the NFL Network good to see
you markets where how are you certain
this awesome and especially seeing a
silhouette right there I remember we
talked about the 40 every single year
and you actually gotten better with the
suit on Whiggish after you lost it that
might be an optical illusion um this
year I got I got set back almost a full
tenth of a second slower which does not
sound like a lot but it was what I
trained with Michael Johnson and
impressed him by getting slower okay you
know but you know I mean the Sun was in
my eyes my Achilles was hurting um what
about oh yeah I had handed a foot and
mouth disease had that too is that an
excuse Brockman very much I don't think
that's a very good one no I just can't
coming up with one after another
good to see you look like you can give
me I can give you about 70 40 snaps
right on where does that give you that
well I mean get back that can get you a
gig in the National Football League
yesterday the market other thing is
though after a while you start thinking
about your body and in life after
football got a little six-year-old a
nine year old and it's you know that
last year you know playing with the
Broncos you just see how much football
takes a toll on your body and you got a
I mean football the short part of your
life so you got to be able to have every
habit for the rest of it okay so two
boys boy and a girl two girls what do
you have little boy little girl six and
nine okay they are growing so are you
taking them to school now and stuff like
take them to school what coaching a flag
football team hold on a second yes I am
coaching you want to see them oh my god
they little plays what do you place
what do you guys got I got a couple
plays loud loud mr. Rickson like a lot
of mixer listen on a second so if you
know so uh where whatever community you
are living in we know our young blade
you are so you were in Texas
okay so somebody's like okay I want my
kid to play flag football they join a
league they show up there are
the team coaches the markets where that
is happening right yeah I go every once
in a while and I mean there's a coaches
here all the time okay and he'll he'll
tics like hey what is the defensive
plays we need to run I say oh I tell you
what we're going to run a zone slash and
man buildings going through because
they're running these types of plays now
we'll actually put like the five kids in
the line cuz it's five on five okay and
like the court the quarterbacks are the
are the coaches and I would have them
going at it the whole time they're like
where these plays coming from are they
running stumps oh no no no this is some
only real cycle flag football game not
man you can't arrest okay if they had
pass rush believe me I would have the
rest professor okay so is it more of a
Wade Phillips design what or is it a
marinelli design what do you got for me
right now right now it's a it's more of
a it's a way Philips design okay so it's
more of a zone zone and blitz type type
defense if you were thinking about that
and what when let's take a break in 60
seconds want to come back want to dig in
more the stuff about your tenure with
Dallas and Denver and what you're doing
now with the Battle of the network is
ours it was fun you are now you're now a
television star DeMarcus Ware trying to
move on I'm following your footstep
learn from the bit well just don't get
slower as you get older that's all it
should test we're back with DeMarcus
Ware in 60 seconds here on the Rich
Eisen chip
[Music]
nobody in the history of football with a
star on the side of their helmets sacked
somebody more than this guy and he
second fastest player ever to reach 100
career sacks the only person to do it
faster than DeMarcus Ware Reggie White
how does that hit you when you hear
those stats now that you have officially
hung them up you know this is just to
think about you know things just like
just steps in general and guide that you
look up to look up like Lawrence Taylor
and look at the Reggie why you know you
did list goes on but when you think
about you being the second most behind
Reggie White I mean it almost gives you
goosebumps
because things like that just don't
happen anymore and to be part of that
and be part of that fraternity is great
did you know Parcells was interested in
you did you know that what's the story
no yeah you know how you go on the
business before the combine and you go
to visit their owner and the coaches and
all my visitor Dallas Cowboys they tell
me we're not interested and so I'm
thinking in my mind well I'm probably
going to go to Sarah Jo Carolina or San
Diego in soon ends 11 pick in the 2005
2005 draft come up the Dallas Cowboys
pick me and you were like I'm like where
did this come from like really but just
to have opportunity to you know meet
with Jerry Jones and with Bill Parcells
Club built ourselves actually wanted
Shawne Merriman that's the route more
than Shawn Marion talked about the
electron Merriman actually yes and he
they actually had a dollar bit telling
me that I won't not my first five years
have 10 SEC whose dollar who made this
dollar but Jerry Jones and uh feel parts
like the Dukes and in trade he races yes
they had a dollar bit Jerry Jones wanted
it yeah
Jerry Jones went a bit and Bill's lunch
scream and turn the machines back up
turn the machines like ah well you're
you definitely were a machine turned on
for sure like what was Parcells like
though of trying to get you to have your
Huggies drop or don't put you in the
Hall of Fame just yet all that sort of
stuff things else does he was one of the
coaches that played the most mind games
with me the whole time and let me tell
you every single day if I didn't hear
about Shawne Merriman
you know what Shawn mérimée had three
sacks you don't have any you know he
might be Rookie of the Year I don't know
if you're going to be able to do that
DeMarcus how you going to rush out of a
six technique meaning being hit to hit
on the tight end and rushing I said well
I like looked at him face to face I said
why don't you stick me outside like
Shawne Merriman and see what I do and he
looks at me like I don't coach Richt
League players I want you to do what I
tell you to do I said you give me one
opportunity to rush outside I said I bet
you $1 he loved the bed I'll get a sack
and he's on the sideline he puts he said
he just says just emotional emotions I
get outside huh I get outside and I go
and get a sack and I turn around I'm
like a kid cuz I'm a rookie and I look
at him and I got that not that Parcells
not like okay you can play outside and
from that point on I've always played a
nine technic technique in his assistant
DeMarcus Ware her on the show what was
it like when Romo took over for blood so
how awkward was that moment it was an
awkward moment because you know you got
drew bledsoe coming in him being the
captain other team other offerings
making sure everything is ran right and
then you have Romo a younger guy that
comes in more of a gunslinger type
quarterback and him coming in and making
plays like no other and from a defensive
guy you're like okay
you have the captain to blood-soaked end
but now Romo is doing very well only
just leaving the game and see what
happens because I think Drew Bledsoe got
hurt at that season and so one step
that's when Romo was born know this when
he got in and got that opportunity and
he didn't turn back ever since
isn't it amazing because we just had dak
Prescott on before you you came out on
the set that that it's it's like just
it's a story with like a mad lib you
just change the names the story's the
same right that you just take out
Bludso's name put Romo's and you take
Romo's name output doc prescott and it's
the same thing and that led to Romo's
end of his tenure in Dallas it's
unbelievable
that's the thing is it's football and
it's not for long
NFL that's that's what it means you can
play as long as you want to and have
great stats but there is someone that's
going to come into the game it's going
to take your spot eventually but you
have to play it as long as you can and
that's what happened with you know Drew
Bledsoe that's what happened with Tony
Romo now you got Dec coming in the game
and that's a new face quarterback for
Dallas Cowboy ideas like Romo is going
to do in the booth I think he's gonna do
well I went to broadcast boot camp and
being a color analyst is freaking or it
is it is very hard I think he will do
well because he's a person that gets to
know each one of the players
individually so you'll be at ad-lib
you'll better tell he can talk football
all day well so can you but so what did
you find so difficult about it I mean
we're so difficult about it I can look
at the football terminology all day but
the little things from like a John
Madden
John Madden would say you know this guy
here runs so hard because his father did
this and this why he runs with so much
tenacity oh I can I can understand why
he runs so hard if you don't have the
entity that bring in the audience to
make things in layman's terms when
similar you make it very simple you're
not going to do well and then you only
have a certain amount of seconds because
you got to turn the motors and I mean it
has to be quick quick
I think Romo is going to be spectacular
I think he is I think he's got a certain
little quality about him that folks
didn't see cuz you when you're the
Dallas Cowboys quarterback and you've
got the Metroplex breathing down your
neck every single second yeah you can't
show off that personality you really
can't he can now he will be able to I
agree with you I agree with you now
DeMarcus Ware here in studio I heard
when you got to Denver that you pulled
that Von Miller aside and taught him a
thing or two about being a professional
and that was needed for him at the time
is that a true story yes I'm coming into
you know different Broncos I knew what
type of potential Vaughn had but I
didn't know what type of work ethic and
classroom mentality he had and I knew
what it took for me me being a guy that
just you learn the X's and O's how they
move how to manipulate them and how to
figure out how to play the game and I
told Vaughn I said Vaughn if you want to
be great since you call me your Idol
you'll listen to me he looks at me like
a little arrogant
prickly this way this one he tells me
and I look at him I said you know I'm
going to show you some example how to
play this game you've done very well but
it's how consistent can you be every
single game we can and week out no
matter if you can chip tonight because I
tell you what you played a great season
but what about when they're chips coming
you still going to have to play well and
he took I took him under my wing and
he's been you know excelling ever since
so how long did you have to break that
veneer of him putting in front of you
that arrogant you know what oh man how
long did it take for you to break
through it then it took about ten months
ten months with Vaughn he would sit
beside me and I know he hated me that's
hit write that down write it down have
you write that down like every single
note write it down Vaughn why don't you
tell me the reason why this you didn't
beat this tackle and he'll you know get
out and practice and he'll just crush
the tackles I say you know there wasn't
fast enough this is what you need to do
to win in this league and he just looked
to me like the markets you're breathing
down my throat and then it got to a
point where I will compete with him in
practice we can and week out and I'll
tell the coaches okay tell them I got
nine pressures in bond got six if I'm
probably had like 15 and he was in front
of the whole team the markets where you
had nine pressures Vaughn you had six I
mean you really have to step it up oh
the next day he will probably have about
25 crush like crush practice I say death
but you have to be every day there's no
on-and-off switch there's not a middle
ground
either you're all night off that's how
you play this game and he just started
taking on that mentality what about the
times you had a text him and go to sleep
I heard about that too
I'll take him go to sleep that he'll
takes me it'll be 2 o'clock at night
he's a man watching film
I said I'm not watching tonight two
o'clock I said pass rushers near if I
could I told him that it so he got to
afford to wear you know it'll be 11
o'clock here go to bed get it get his
rest and now you know he's been he's
been doing really do it I don't know
let's say he just was ranked number two
behind he's already on the top 100 list
on the NFL Network we all know I mean of
all the Super Bowls to be named the MVP
as a defender to a nice nice round
number
yes right and with you and Peyton
Manning is to send both of you off right
yes so have you talked to I know you
don't talk about these things but I'll
say ask any we talked about with Peyton
that you would go to can't know how
together I am talk to you know Peyton
about it at all I mean we usually we've
never been like stat guys I really
wanted to I got no I don't know just no
I was just humble about things I
absolutely been chilly it'll come to a
point though what we really talked about
it we talked about the memory sometimes
of any DeMarcus remember in the locker
room I mean even when I was hurt and you
was hurt your back was hurt and we were
talking about in the training room when
you know Brock goes in or you know Shaq
or Shane they're going to the game and
how we played and how you know if we're
in the locker room if we're sitting back
and we can't go out in practice we're
looking out from a window and it's
snowing outside we would say yeah we
don't want to be out there but how can
we help the team those types of memories
are going to last forever with me and
Peyton and you know hopefully you know
like you just said both of us going and
getting together I would be unbelievable
what do you think he's going to do what
do you think paint man is going to do
DeMarcus Ware keep playing pranks on
everyone like they always do I'm sure
what he's going to have to figure
something out when people talk politics
people talk about becoming an owner
people talk about they don't to be great
him being the owner of a team he knows
exactly like a Elway deal but because
they know the mentality of the players
they know what it takes and they start
from top and go all the way to the
bottom to this to the small guy and him
being owner of a team would be big-time
well I mean Elway doesn't own the
Broncos is obviously you know but people
are saying that he would
that's one thing but Elway here Chloe
this would be I know but Manning owning
a team not just not being the grocery
shop or not running the operations
owning the team if if Payton owned the
team he's also going to grocery shop he
wants it all um he was he was general
manager and owner
DeMarcus very the DeMarcus fear on the
show let's take a break come back we'll
talk about your your your battle and
network stars gig and what you're
playing in the - it's great to see
Marcus where we're back with more with
DeMarcus Ware before Tom Arnold strolls
in here
look out well here we're arms and that's
next year i'll show
my pillow calm it is the spot for you to
get the best night's sleep possible
thanks to this pillow pillow these
pillows are made for exactly how you are
sleep are you a side sleeper or some
explode your back sleeper I love pillow
DeMarcus Ware there's a pillow for you
at my pillow calm is what you do you go
to my pillow calm put the promo code
enriched or call 865-465-2249 well I
want to know though if I put your name
in there yes / where will the other 50%
oh gosh you begin to make my pillow free
look they don't play anymore great
exactly like anymore that whole if it's
free it's me type of thing that you've
been enjoying ever since you left the
campus at Troy that's out the window I'm
willing to give you this promo code rich
okay my polka so how did you enjoy the
battle the network stars that debuts on
ABC on Thursday night it was so much fun
13 culture I'm a team coach I never
watched it because it started in 1976
and I remember in four four people that
have watched it they have the actors
that went through all the obstacle
courses and trying to figure out who
does what will and now with me and
Rhonda coming in and being the coaches
of each Rowsey we are under a yeah and
if you're trying to make actors and
athletes and take them through the
obstacle courses and every detail from
the Oh show is on a new show but just a
better twist to it
couple extra obstacles like soccer
basketball maybe archery kayak
some of the things that are that were on
the old show but it was so much fun to
meet the other personality well I
remember battle of the Network Stars
Howard Cosell always doing the sideline
reporting of it or the hosting of it and
it would be like there's Gabe Kaplan
fresh off the set of Welcome Back Kotter
taking part in the tug of war with
Robert Conrad tough guy Robert Conrad
versus gay here comes telly savalas like
that's the way it used to be that's
exactly what is I know except it's
Telly Savalas it's tomorrow is coming up
in our throw like now how good at the
tug of war was come on so he was he was
awesome at the tug-of-war he didn't do
many of the other events yes but when it
came down to the tug-of-war
yes he did awesome okay you know awesome
and you know he's a die-hard giant fan
he's tight with me okay I should have
put him in the front of the officer
front of the the tug of war if we can
put in the West you know as you seen was
on the back he was on the anger give me
an acre
he was the anchor he he look my thinker
oh my god this is will you come back
your DeMarcus Carter come offering you
in Los Angeles not too old I'm actually
a lot more now okay a lot more now but I
will come one so this is my house is
your Steve Smith spent all three hours
with us yesterday Marshall Faulk did
three hours with us on Friday you come
here and hang out / please any time / if
you're not just I'm not just saying that
oh you're not just saying that I'm not
just saying it first five years in the
league DeMarcus Ware sixty four and a
half sex there is a lot of fat how about
Shawne Merriman
43 Dan Wow before we say goodbye to
DeMarcus Ware one day no no one day one
day hold on one day
I'm on the NFL Network you know where
I'm going with this yes yeah
interviewing OSI you mean you're on the
set and I say the best player out of
Troy in the National Football League is
sitting right here and I got like a text
from somebody named DeMarcus pretty ah
excuse me I went to Troy we were not
happy with me I was hot phones buzzing
right in the middle my ultimate my
blackberry was blessed buzz that's how
long ago was not to date this little way
back we do look a little bigger a little
bit and look at us now yes great to see
you DeMarcus thank you DeMarcus Ware
check out Battle of the Network Stars
starting tomorrow at 9:00 Eastern on ABC
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy